you started on vine um and youtube and
now obviously like you're massive
on tick-tock this ain't a race tony
lopez caught a case
nessa shut it all up on josh's face
pretty
itty-bitty tiny weights don't want the
smoke but
charlie had that bait was music always
sort of the goal
not really i'm i've always okay the fun
thing i have
my journal when i was like nine or like
10
and my grandma recently found it from
roadhouse and in my journal i
specifically wrote
i'm gonna be a music star i'm gonna be a
rock star and you guys are gonna all be
upset when i am because at the time no
one accepted me for who i was and i was
like
i'm getting my mom so proud and she's
gonna apologize for all that i was just
really going crazy
but i knew music was something i was
good at like i
i can freestyle i can write lyrics i i
have a good tempo i'm good on b
i can do all that but it's not something
i want to take seriously
like i'm just doing it for fun you know
what i mean
i don't want to like i don't want to
make everything feel like a job
because you know once you start filling
a job you'll get burnt out right now i'm
living my best life i'm having so much
fun doing what i do
so does that mean no more music at all
or will you
absolutely i have a few things on my
sleeve you know i'm not gonna just
i'm not gonna end it off with just
cancelled come on
what what's up your sleeve i will say
there is a few collabs with some cool
artists that
are being talked about and you know
there are some cool songs that i haven't
released that just might end up being
released
but other than that i'm just we're just
fighting you know we're just writing off
the cancel way
i didn't expect this song to go the way
it did at all i thought the song was
going to do like
the least views of a video i've ever had
but it was honestly like i did it for
fun and i know people liked it i did not
think it was going to get 40 million
views in literally like two weeks
what would your dream collaboration be
my dream collaboration would probably be
i would have to say nicki minaj
these ugly this is really boosting my
ego
like duh who doesn't like nicki minaj i
mean yeah have you ever met her
no okay that would be insane
my mannequin would possibly collapse do
you have an idea for a song with her
no because i it's not realistic but
if it were to happen it would possibly
like i don't know how to react to it i
think i would answer them like
sorry for my language like i would
do it i don't know how to react to it
that's amazing
i do know correct me if i'm wrong but
you're also a massive miley fan
right who told you this are you
um well my username came from her
i used to be a fan account for miley
cyrus and her name is miley ray cyrus i
mean my name
laira cyrus was my username and i kept
the right because i was like
that's low-key spicy yeah
so i kept it and no one really knows
that
but a few people we know that yeah as
you said
all it's like uh it's embarrassing but
you know we all start somewhere i guess
what i mean how many followers did you
have on your miley cyrus fan account
i had like five thousand that's pretty
good actually
yeah cause i was also making vines too
at the time so yeah did you
have you met miley no
how do we make this happen i thought i
could meet noah before miley but
miley babe i just want to meet you i
i literally was just listening to her
album bangers before i got here which is
kind of crazy
is so good oh god i came in
[Music]
there's so much love i have towards that
woman the woman i would die for is her
ariana and billy
and nikki i would die for those women
for all of them they're all such amazing
artists
when did your when did your love for
miley first start like was there a
moment
it was obviously during hannah montana
but then that era stopped then bangers
just went like i was like this is a bad
one once bigger came out
that's what she had me on the hook yeah
i've been like keeping i've been
watching her every move ever since even
to this day
ron don't blink ride leave it to the
double thick thousand sisters
people of course know you from the hype
house
are you still affiliated with a hype
house hang out with them yeah
okay how did you get involved like did
thomas reach out to you or how did that
all
happen it was more so just hanging out
we were i was just hanging out with all
of them addison
chase thomas nick reilly alex
and cover they're all already space for
me those are
really great friends yeah
will you be part of the hype house
reality show
i don't know i don't because i obviously
can't predict the future
so i'm not really sure because i have a
lot of other stuff that i have to work
on myself
why don't you share your personal life
okay let me explain this in the easiest
way possible
um i'm genuinely scared people i get
judge all the time
on the internet for doing the bare
minimum right
and i'm just so scared that if i start
getting vulnerable and opening up and
showing you my personal life they're
going to have something more to judge
but it doesn't hurt me now because
they're judging a persona they don't
know they don't really know
they're judging someone that they never
met they're judging someone that's not
really
100 me because like i'm scared i'm i
have trust issues and i'm sensitive and
i don't i don't want to open up to
absolutely everybody
but i'm just really terrified for being
judged from the internet
about personal things that i actually
care about you know what i mean i do but
that makes
my heart yeah such a light
and i feel like people
want to know you but i also understand
you have to do it on your own time and
i understand the internet is a really
trolly
place the internet's full of trolls but
yeah i'm like you ever see that do you
ever see that changing
yeah i feel like i will i'm still trying
to figure out you know
you know myself and how comfortable i am
with myself
i'm still working on like not being
insecure and not letting people's
opinions get to you as much as i preach
on the internet saying like don't let
people affect you or like don't let
people
you know bring you down but it's also
really or it's really hard
like it really is um but as soon as i'm
done with that it's overall you
as soon as i i have a movie coming out
soon is it the time travel movie
it is what can you tell us about it so i
will be playing a character as myself
right because you know not all youtubers
who take doctors can be actors even
though you
have made a couple of skits in my life
i'm playing this role as myself which
means it's my personality it's my
responses it's literally just me
in a movie literally me in a movie but
basically i'm going back in time
and i'm not gonna have all the things or
like the clown like i'm just it's just
literally me
restarting life and going to be
going through obstacles of like me in
the 1960s or like me with queen
elizabeth or like me seeing my grandma
when she was younger like it's gonna be
crazy stuff like that so
what would you be like without the fame
hypothetically i was thinking about this
if i didn't become like a youtuber a
tick tucker
where would i be and i was i would
honestly get in school right now
what would you be studying i would be a
veterinarian
oh you love animals i love animals so
much i love that
it's crazy i was i went to school to be
a vet but then i ended up not going back
and now i'm a youtuber who
wants you do you see yourself ever
going back absolutely i want to i want
to do school i feel like school's in
quarter and i feel like
and i'm so good at school regardless of
anything if i ever
need to go back to school i can do it in
slay because i'm back in high school and
tell them to like i had great grades you
know
super easy i like the thought process of
doing something and completing it
so school is just simple for me and i
feel like being a veterinarian be so
dope for me i would be so cute with the
little vest
and like my little cats and stuff yes
and you're
yeah like your lab coat oh absolutely
like with the horses and i'm like
checking the heartbeat like i could say
that
go into that when when can we expect to
see this movie
is it gonna be streaming in theaters
um i can't really say much i know every
youtuber and
every social media influencer say that
but i really can't say much because i'm
i can't say much well is it in
production yet
not yet we start um in november or i
think
in december so soon what we started
okay if it was up to you would it be in
theaters you're good at your job i live
for it
um
i will most definitely probably i'm not
going to confirm but yes maybe be in
theaters who knows
depending on life or whatever the world
has for me
diamonds shine like dinos i go hard like
dinner
snap like thanos where do you see the
like your brand going in the next 10
years i feel like you're talented
you have your hand in so many different
things you're obviously very creative
i'm just curious what your your future
looks like
me too um that's my biggest fear is not
knowing what it's going to look like but
i feel due to the fact that i'm so
motivated and driven by multiple things
i can see myself being very happy
with like the way my life will be i hope
i will have kids i'm not kidding i have
the worst baby people right now
i almost adopted a dalmatian yet like
two days ago because i wanted a child so
i think it's a different supplement
like it's bad so i most definitely will
be a doctor
i can in 10 years 10 to 5 right yeah i
can see myself in a nice house with my
lovely husband and my two kids
iris and alexander you already have the
names picked out
boys it's bad i literally have the word
i want to be a father so bad
you would be a good dad i know i would
when is your next i know
you're not gonna do another diss track
but like when can we hear more
i don't know music from you like what's
your next big project we could see you
in
it's time for you to take over the world
in my opinion i will say
my i'm working i'm currently working on
a collab with some very cool artists
um but who who
can tell you as much as i want to you're
just like i want to tell you absolutely
everything
i can leave my diary while you're at it
can i
yeah i'll leave it for you
um but um yeah that's my main that's my
main that's the main focus right now
just working on
you know i feel like it'll be dope once
you guys figure out who it is or find
out who it is you would really do enjoy
it
will you give us a hint it's a female
a pop artist a tick-tocker is it dixie
yeah you got me i'm just kidding
i'm gonna dick's gun the canceled remix
i would love to see that before i let
you go do you have a message just to
your fans i mean it's crazy wild times
right now
yeah a message to my lovely fans um
thank you for supporting me through
everything that i've been through and i
know i'm annoying and i know i'm
stressful
but the fact that everyone puts up with
me just really shows that you guys care
and it blows my mind
okay it blows my mind i don't know if it
blows yours but people care
it's so weird that people care so much
about the things that i do
like i don't it hasn't processed yet but
like i can literally
post something and people care so much
and i'm just like
is that ever like scary to know how much
power you have
i don't think of it because i feel like
thinking of it i'll start doing dumb
so i just i just let him ride you know
i'm just like
but i'm so used to people not caring
that i have something that cares just
like wow
like maybe maybe i'm not a loser
mary huh maybe
you